qu'un des sites dont il assure la gestion,
une page web d'extrême-droite, devait être bloquée.
Il a envoyé un courriel privé à ses collègues :
« C'était une décision arbitraire.
Je me suis levé du mauvais pied ce matin
et j'ai décidé de les virer d'Internet. »
Il a même admis que
« personne ne devrait avoir ce pouvoir ».
En réponse, l'un de ses employés lui a demandé :
« Internet est-il mort ce jour ? »
Je ne crois pas que nous détruisons Internet,
mais nous sommes au beau milieu
d'un mouvement de centralisation irresponsable
qui fragilise notre Internet.
Le réseau décentralisé, de personne à personne,
résout ce problème en éliminant les éléments centraux,
les services d'hébergement web.
Il donne le pouvoir aux utilisateurs
qui hébergent eux-mêmes les sites qu'ils veulent conserver.
Sur ce réseau, les sites sont directement téléchargés par les autres visiteurs.
C'est-à-dire que si un site a 100 visiteurs,
il est hébergé par 100 ordinateurs à travers le monde.
Tout simplement, c'est une version d'Internet alimentée par les gens.
Un chiffrement à clé publique assure la sécurité du réseau,
de façon à ce que personne ne puisse modifier les sites,
excepté son propriétaire.
C'est comme si, au lieu de recevoir l'électricité de grandes centrales,
vous posiez des panneaux solaires sur le toit.
Et si vos voisins ont besoin d'un peu plus d'énergie,
ils peuvent s'approvisionner un peu depuis votre maison.
En utilisant le réseau décentralisé,
on peut faire en sorte que le contenu reste accessible à d'autres visiteurs.
Et de cette manière, je veux dire
que nous pouvons aussi lutter contre les choses
que nous estimons injustes,
comme la censure.
En Chine, Internet est étroitement contrôlé.
Impossible de critiquer le gouvernement,
d'organiser une manifestation,
et il est aussi interdit de publier
un émoticône qui rappelle les victimes du massacre de la place Tian'anmen.
Avec le réseau décentralisé, ce n'est pas l’État qui décide
de ce qui est visible ou non.
Ce sont les gens qui décident,
ce qui rend le web plus démocratique.
Mais en même temps, c'est dur d'utiliser ce réseau
pour faire quelque chose de clairement illégal
dans le monde entier,
car les utilisateurs ne veulent probablement pas se mettre en danger
en hébergeant ce type de contenu douteux.
Une autre menace croissante
pour la liberté d'Internet,
c'est la réglementation excessive.
J'ai l'impression
que nos représentants politiques,
qui votent les lois réglementant Internet,
ne se rendent pas complétement compte de leurs décisions.
Par exemple, le Parlement Européen débat d'une nouvelle loi
sur la protection des droits d'auteur,
dont une partie est intitulée l'article 13.
Si cette loi est adoptée, chaque grand site Internet devra
mettre en place un filtre
pour bloquer automatiquement du contenu
selon des règles contrôlées par des multinationales.
L'idée était de protéger les contenus soumis au droit d'auteur,
mais elle menacerait beaucoup de nos actions sur Internet :
tenir un blog, critiquer, discuter et partager.
Google et YouTube ont déjà mis en place des systèmes de ce type
et ils reçoivent 100 000 demandes de retrait de contenu par heure.
Bien sûr, ils ne peuvent pas traiter seuls un tel volume de données,
ils utilisent l'apprentissage automatique
pour savoir s'il y a ou non violation des droits d'auteur.
Mais ces filtres font des erreurs.
Ils enlèvent tout, des documents sur les violations des droits de l'homme,
aux conférences sur les droits d'auteur,
en passant par les résultats de recherches
qui amènent vers des critiques de ce nouvel article 13.
En plus de cela, ils enlèvent aussi beaucoup d'autres choses.
Et parfois, ces filtres ne suppriment pas seulement le contenu mis en cause,
mais ils peuvent aussi éliminer tous vos comptes affiliés :
votre adresse courriel, vos documents, vos photos
ou votre livre inachevé,
c'est ce qui est arrivé à l'écrivain Dennis Cooper.
Ce n'est pas difficile de voir comment un tel système peut être détourné
par des politiciens ou des entreprises concurrentes.
L'article 13, l'extension de ces filtres automatisés à l'ensemble d'Internet,
a suscité une vive opposition
de la part de Wikipedia, Github, Mozilla et bien d'autres,
y compris les créateurs d'Internet et du World Wide Web,
Vint Cerf et Tim Berners-Lee.
Mais, malgré cette vive opposition,
lors du dernier vote au Parlement européen,
deux tiers des eurodéputés ont soutenu cette loi.
Le vote final aura lieu début 2019.
Le verdict est important,
mais quelle qu'en soit l'issue,
je suis persuadé qu'il sera suivi par bien d'autres propositions de ce type
dans le monde entier.
Ce type de réglementation serait très difficile à appliquer
dans un réseau décentralisé,
sans hébergeurs,
où les sites web sont pris en charge par les visiteurs eux-mêmes.
J'ai commencé à construire ce réseau il y a trois ans.
Depuis lors, j'ai passé des milliers, des dizaines de milliers d'heures
sur son développement.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi passer des milliers d'heures sur une chose qu'on peut librement copier,
renommer ou même revendre ?
Dans mon cas,
une des raisons était de réaliser une action qui a du sens.
Dans mon travail quotidien de développeur web,
je n'ai pas le sentiment de travailler sur quelque chose
qui aurait une chance de devenir plus grand que moi.
Je voulais seulement que ma courte présence sur Terre
ait du sens.
L'année dernière, le Grand Pare-feu de Chine s'est mis à bloquer ce réseau.
Ce qui a officiellement fait de moi l'ennemi
de la censure sur Internet soutenue par les États.
Depuis lors, c'est un vrai jeu du chat et de la souris.
Ils créent de nouvelles règles dans le pare-feu
et j'essaie d'y réagir aussi vite que possible
pour que les gens puissent continuer à héberger et à créer des sites web
qui seraient autrement censurés par l'Internet centralisé chinois.
Mon autre motivation à créer ce réseau a été la crainte.
J'ai peur que le futur d'Internet soit hors de notre contrôle.
La centralisation croissante et les projets de loi
menacent notre liberté d'expression
et, par là même, notre démocratie.
Pour moi, créer un réseau décentralisé,
c'est créer un refuge,
où les règles ne sont pas écrites par des multinationales ou des partis politiques,
mais par les gens.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)